[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCOIS ALLIOT: I
really think developing
a game is like writing a novel.
I studied literature, but
I also studied history.
You can play with history using
cliche, if you want to be funny
and to create a gap between
something that's old
and something that's modern.
I really think that coding and
writing are of the same nature.
You have some way
to name things,
to structure your
logic, which is very
similar to writing a sentence.
I developed "Reigns" in my
house, me and my computer.
I launched the first version
the week my son was born.
It was a great deadline for me.
"Reigns" was a
nine month project,
so it's like a pregnancy.
That was a stressful time.
My life changed
because of my son.
I really wanted to be
present in this life.
Working as an indie
game developer
is very good for that.
It's very easy to
work on your own.
That is not how you make games.
You can't design
every little point.
You have to have the skill
of being able to go to people
and show your stuff.
It brings a new
perspective and new ideas.
That's super important.
Once you are able
to try new things,
it gives freedom, so I may
go to work wherever I want,
and I'm able to work with people
from everywhere in the world.
I look back on the journey I've
been on in such short time,
and it's a little overwhelming.
"Reigns" is a mix of Tinder
and "Game of Thrones."
Swipe your own adventure.
We used a lot of evocation.
With just a few words
and a few sentences,
you should be able to imagine
yourself in the skin of a king.
I think the first time I
was happy with the game
was when I saw someone playing
and they started to laugh,
and that's the moment I knew
we had something different.
Google Play was helpful
to build success,
to push the game at that
very crucial moments
and pave the way for
1.5 million downloads.
The Google Play indie game
contest was very good for that.
It's importance for your
exposure to go and try things.
You have to make the most of
every opportunity you're given.
The industry of mobile
games is quite new.
We know our users
are hungry for it.
They want more
stories, more "Reigns."
We're only scratching the
surface of what we can do.